bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette édition du 7 8 lectue du
Jeudi 6 février comme tous les soirs
nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale tout d'abord
attention à l'alerte orange soulevé sur
les Yvelines météo France prévoit des
vents violents qui devraient arriver
cette nuit sur les coups de 3 heures du
matin sur le département cela devrait
souffler aux alentours des 100 km/h
jusqu'à demain matin 10h soyez donc très
prudent lors de votre départ au travail
nous vous l'annoncions en social la
semaine dernière 1400 suppressions de
postes chez Airbus group anciennement
appelé EADS sont à prévoir d'ici trois
ans on parlait alors de 411 emplois
touchés sur le site d'Élancourt
notamment en cause la restructuration du
groupe type comprendra trois divisions
parmi elles ADS qui regroupera Cassidian
et astriaum 309 emplois seraient
également touché au Mureaux mais pour le
syndicat cfe-cgcc chiffre sont à prendre
avec des pincettes car les effectifs de
salariés avancés pour chaque site
concerné dans les Yvelines lors de cette
annonce ne de correspondrait pas du tout
à la réalité explication avec Philippe
vanglas directeur syndical de cassidian
il y a un chiffre de 411 qui a été fait
c'est
un chiffre mais ce chiffre pour moi il
veut rien dire en tous les cas je sais
pas si ça concerne cassidien SAS je ne
sais pas si ça concerne que Élancourt en
faisant des plus et les moyens notre
filiale qui est sûr Élancourt qui fait
plus 156 personnes dans deux ans donc si
on dit que les 411 ça tient compte qu'il
y en a 156 qui sont placés en de là on
monte à 560 suppression de poste nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est les
suppressions de poste c'est pas le bilan
final donc on a beaucoup de mal à suivre
ce que ça veut dire 411 aujourd'hui le
400 je sais pas qui s'applique et quel
contour est-ce que c'est aussi notre
filiale abscisse qui assure N ou pas
j'en sais rien obligatoire depuis 1951
l'euro le recensement de la population
s'effectue en ce moment même du 16
janvier au 22 février nous avons suivi
un agent recenseur sur le terrain à
plaisir qui distribue et collecte les
imprimés de l'Insee Olivier Maniscalco
et Patrick Jacques delicme
le recensement c'est maintenant jusqu'au
22 février les agents recenseurs font le
tour des villes pour distribuer les
questionnaires de l'Insee a plaisir ils
sont six dont Muriel racheter qui
travaillait pour la mairie de la ville
et s'est porté volontaires pour cette
mission sur son temps libre midi soir et
week-end elle vient munie de son badge
d'agent sonné aux portes afin de
distribuer les imprimés du recensement
nous avons donc un nombre d'adresses
limitées donc moi j'en ai
170 donc le 170 ça peut être énormément
de personnes il peut avoir une personne
par adresse mais comme il peut en avoir
beaucoup là aujourd'hui j'ai un immeuble
une adresse un immeuble avec 100
logements
une fois les questionnaires récupérés
ils vont être transmis à l'INSEE où ils
seront analysés l'évaluation de
l'Institut va permettre de définir en
fonction du nombre d'habitants la
dotation globale de fonctionnement versé
par l'État à la municipalité l'analyse
servira également à établir les besoins
en personnels pour les services publics
de la ville comme les crèches par
exemple le recensement est donc utile
pour les habitants qui s'y plie en
général sans difficulté
pour pour commander rechercher des
informations ou des choses comme ça
comme autrement c'est clair de voir le
citoyen ça permet je pense de savoir un
peu
le nombre de personnes et puis
le type de personne aussi qui vit de
population type de population
dans cette ville en particulier pour ce
travail chaque âge j'en recenseur touche
un peu plus de 1000 euros chaque année
8% de la population est interrogée les
chiffres de l'INSEE sont ensuite établis
tous les 5 ans
place à la prévention maintenant majeure
des cow-bonsoir vous êtes présent sur le
plateau du statut de l'actu ce soir car
le camion de l'unité de prévention des
conduitaristes sillonnent pendant un
mois les Yvelines et cette semaine vous
avez notamment fait étape au Lycée Henri
Matisse de trappe tout d'abord première
question quel est votre mission auprès
des jeunes justement alors écoutez ben
policier formateur anti-drogue c'est un
acteur de prévention des conduites des
risques des conduites addictifs pardon
donc il va sensibiliser les adolescents
sur les drogues il va informer et
prévenir aussi des actions en menant des
actions de sensibilisation auprès des
jeunes sur les dangers des drogues
éventuellement et comment avec ces
dangers des drogues il va rappeler les
lois il va aussi responsabiliser les
adolescents sur la responsabilité pénale
dans ce domaine il va aussi mener des
actions dans le commandant d'information
pardon auprès des parents et des
professeurs à ne pas négliger puisqu'on
travaille aussi avec les collèges et les
lycées notamment avec les comités à
l'éducation et à la santé des
sites-t-on dans le terme conduite à
risque bien écoutez c'est toutes les
conduites qui vont mener malheureusement
des problématiques d'agressivité de
dangerosité de violence et ça peut être
aussi sous forme de prise de substances
de produits qu'on appelle souvent des
drogues et parfois on a des idées reçues
et souvent les jeunes pensent que tel et
tel produit ou drogue est-ce que c'est
une drogue ou pas et c'est ce qu'on met
en place dès le premier temps quand on
fait des actions de prévention comment
définir une drogue qu'est-ce que c'est
que pour un jeune la drogue ou les
drogues oui justement peut-être que la
plupart de votre combat c'est aussi
entre les justement battre ses idées
reçues ces préjugés sur les droits
notamment effectivement il faut faire
comprendre aux adolescents que c'est
dangereux parce qu'ils sont vulnérables
à cet âge-là ils n'ont pas encore la fin
ils sont pas encore tout à fait formés
et
dès les premières consommations ils
peuvent devenir dépendants la dépendance
et on peut pas se poser du produit sous
peine d'avoir une souffrance et donc dès
les premières prises de produits en
expérimentant ils peuvent avoir cette
dépendance le danger il est là donc on
est là aussi pour leur faire comprendre
que malgré tout prendre une première
expérimentation d'un produit ça peut
devenir derrière une dépendance donc
retarder ses premières consommations et
surtout ne pas commencer alors je vous
propose de les écouter ces élèves que
vous avez rencontrés au lycée Henri
Matisse cette semaine on va voir un peu
ce qu'ils ont pensé de votre
intervention
faire intéressant parce que il y a des
choses qu'on savait pas qu'on a appris
et je pense que ça peut apporter
beaucoup d'amaclasse pour des choses
qu'on fait qui sont pas très bien j'ai
beaucoup de gens dans ma famille qui ont
des problèmes avec l'alcool et la drogue
donc
voilà et je trouve ça super intéressant
parce que peut-être il y en a dans la
classe il pensait que ça se passait pas
comme ça qui avait des accidents ou
voilà
justement c'est symptomatiques ces
réponses on savait pas que ça se passait
comme ça c'est souvent la réponse que
vous donne les jeunes souvent ils ont
des idées préconçues ils ont parfois des
préjugés sur certaines choses où il
pense qu'ils connaissent certaines
substances or quand on parle des drogues
les trois drogues les plus consommés en
France ce sont le tabac l'alcool et le
cannabis donc parfois ils disent et le
tabac c'est une drogue bah oui regardez
autour de vous si jamais vous enlevez
une première cigarette à quelqu'un qui
fume régulièrement vous allez voir
est-ce qu'il va être son comportement
est-ce qu'il va être normal
effectivement quand on fume quand on
prend une drogue il y a un comportement
une modification du comportement c'est
ce qu'on leur apprend quel message
justement vouloir vous leur donnez
au-delà de cette caractérisation de la
drogue
moi je pense enfin c'est pas moi je
pense excusez-moi mais l'important c'est
de leur faire comprendre et de le faire
réfléchir qu'il faut savoir dire non il
ne faut pas banaliser ses premières
consommations c'est dangereux la loi est
là aussi pour rappeler qu'elle protège
et donc parce que c'est dangereux donc
on applique un petit peu tout ce qui est
responsabilité pénale parce que c'est
répréhensible aussi pour des produits
stupéfiants interdits néanmoins il faut
le rappeler que dire non c'est aussi
être quelqu'un et avoir une personnalité
pour pas justement enclencher et un
phénomène de dépendance qui pourra
arriver très vite et alors est-ce que
ces jeunes sont de plus en plus nombreux
vous les voyez plus en plus nombreux
justement les consommer ces drogues ou
plutôt peut-être plus en plus nombreux
plutôt tout varie un petit peu tout
dépend de de certains produits néanmoins
on sait que aujourd'hui à 11 ans on peut
essayer et commencer à essayer le tabac
que le cannabis en être un petit peu
plus tardivement vers 14 ans que les
garçons sont enclins à prendre
comment du cannabis plus que les filles
néanmoins des consommations existent
elles sont à la période d'adolescence la
période la plus vulnérable et la plus
fragile alors je sais que au-delà des
jeunes vous avez d'autres publics vous
intervenez aussi dans dans les
entreprises notamment c'est aussi un une
pratique qui se VUL malheureusement dans
ce milieu là écoutez on est quand même
dans une société où on demande aux
personnes d'être performant et donc
parfois il arrive que certaines
personnes pour justement garder cette
performance tout au long de la journée
bah peuvent s'adonner à des pratiques
enfin des pratiques à des prises de
substance qui peuvent leur donner un
booster qui peuvent leur donner une
sensation d'être réveillé toute la
journée néanmoins il y a toujours une
conséquence
lorsqu'on prend un produit bah il y a le
corps qui dit stop et donc ça peut aussi
amener à des choses parfois dramatiques
comme on peut le voir dans certaines
entreprises donc c'est vrai que nous on
mène aussi des actions auprès des
entreprises dans ce domaine qui sont
quels sont que sont pardon les
conduitaristes justement à propos des
jeunes pour revenir aux jeunes c'est
difficile parfois le départ d'un atelier
comme cela dans la rencontre le dialogue
a du mal à se nouer parce que il faut se
confier quand même mine de rien c'est
quand même c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident mais c'est vrai que moi je fais
partie du service comment partenariat
police population et c'est vrai que leur
explique je suis pas un policier
différent j'inter jamais en tenue Hermée
et je leur explique que à tout moment je
peux intervenir néanmoins on essaie
comme en intervenir avec un climat de
confiance une empathie et on leur donne
la possibilité de s'exprimer et c'est
surtout on va travailler beaucoup sur
les comportements qu'est-ce qui réagisse
qu'est-ce qu'ils pensent c'est quoi pour
une drogue comment il ils vont
l'interpréter on fait une système de
brestorming pour savoir un petit peu
tous les mots qui vont un petit peu être
dit concernant les drogues et après on
essaie de travailler sur les
comportements sur la responsabilité
pénale les lois forcément puisque il y a
des choses qui sont interdites tout
n'est pas autorisé très bien et c'est
vrai que l'utilisation des drogues est
parfois interdit par la loi merci
beaucoup majorette venu sur le site actu
et peut-être à bientôt pour de nouvelles
interventions sur ces produits à risque
c'est une structure exclusivement
réservée aux hommes seuls en difficulté
à Versailles le bétel c'est son nom
existe depuis 20 ans et accueille neuf
résidents le temps d'une année maximum
admission recommandations des
travailleurs sociaux tels que les
membres du CCAS ou des éducateurs
spécialisés ils construisent un projet
de réinsertion Yolaine Torres et
Jonathan Wilman
Victor est arrivé au betel il y a
quelques jours sans emploi expulser son
logement cela faisait un an qu'il
dormait dans des voitures ou des garages
c'est finalement son assistante sociale
qu'il a orienté vers cette structure
d'accueil pour Romandie
blanchi et nourri pour seulement 250
euros par mois il peut mener son projet
de réinsertion dans de bonnes conditions
déjà vous avez un toit vous êtes en
sécurité vous pouvez vous alimenter
et puis ensuite
aller aux tâches quotidiennes qui
aujourd'hui dans mon cas est de
rechercher un emploi très rapidement
trouver un emploi rapidement
ancien technicien Victor souhaite
aujourd'hui se réorienter vers
l'humanitaire comme lui ils sont neufs à
pouvoir bénéficier de cet accueil un
accueil exclusivement réservé aux hommes
seuls souvent passés dans la rue et
ayant la volonté de sortir de leur
situation le temps d'un an maximum
chacun dispose d'une chambre
individuelle de la cuisine de la salle
de bain et du salon commun
il y a aussi des règles à respecter et
dans ces règles-là c'est à dire qu'ils
ont ce qu'on appelle
un planning hebdomadaire et chacun des
tâches par exemple il y en a qui va être
référent pour préparer à manger la
semaine il y en a un qui va laver le
salon nous sommes une annonce qui va
laver le couloir le premier étage etc
chacun a des missions à respecter
subventionné en majeure partie par la
Direction Départementale de la Cohésion
sociale des Yvelines le bétel fait
partie de l'association SOS accueil qui
mène plusieurs actions en 2013 sur les
26 résidents reçus ici 10 d'entre eux
ont trouvé un logement et un emploi
souvent les autres retournent dans leur
famille quittent la région où sont
réorientés vers d'autres structures
nous vous l'annoncions mardi dans notre
édition Émile Legat dirigeant du club de
football de Guyancourt avait disparu
dans la journée de lundi son corps a
malheureusement été retrouvé sans vie
dans le bois des bouviers et au départ
d'une battue organisée par les
sapeurs-pompiers et les policiers avait
visiblement quitté son domicile pour une
promenade et n'était jamais rentrée cet
homme de 80 ans avait dévoué plus de 30
ans de sa vie au football et au club 50
chinois ce week-end une minute de
silence sera observée en sa mémoire
avant le coup d'envoi de toutes les
rencontres des équipes guyancourtoise
toutes nos pensées évidemment à tout ces
proches avant de nous quitter je vous
rappelle cette information développée en
début de journal Météo France à signaler
une alerte orange au vent violent sur le
département des Yvelines des rafales qui
pourront aller jusqu'à 100 km/h et
soufflerons cette nuit à partir de 3
heures du matin jusqu'à 10h soyez donc
prudent en cas de sortie c'est la fin de
ce 7 8 lactu merci de l'avoir suivi à
18h30 vous retrouverez votre émission
économique Fido évidemment avec claire
Cambier quant à moi je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur TV film